foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
what is the inspiration is it like water
is it spirit is it it's the unraveling
of a flower
how do you get around with how do you
get around with that how have you moved
how did you get here in that I got here
by being carried
They Carried me literally and dropped me
right here but um it's not that bad it's
not heavy it's just very fluffy have you
seen Rihanna's performance of what she's
gonna do tonight have I seen it you've
seen it no I didn't know you may have
been in rehearsal It's Your Song oh no
no no no no I'm looking forward to
seeing how that's going to be like the
high that the highlight of my night and
I can't wait it's gonna be amazing and
you're sitting there as a nominee it's
incredible so blessed is it wild when
you walk down this carpet and you look
at everybody and you're like I could
walk go home tonight with a damn Oscar
like Gabrielle Union was fangirling over
you does that sit with you now there are
so many celebrities that fan girl over
you it's nice first of all she is an
absolute sweet woman and it's it's
surreal because she's I'm in front of
her she was like oh you're my son and
that was incredible it is surreal yeah
good luck tonight
yeah yeah
[Music]